The joe rogan experience.
[inaudible]
pros,
professional players,
what do you have to learn?
Like what are the principles?
Well,
you can learn the fundamentals,
like how to kind of stand the right way to hit a ball.
But learning how to do things,
we'll look all like learning how to move the ball correctly.
Like shot like this.
Most people have no idea where I'm going to get from there to the four ball.
So I want to get out of here.
You have to hit the four bolts,
the four balls,
next
three after three.
I've got to get into position for the forest.
So I hit it flat so it slides out.
And so I don't just do that,
but I also took a steamer.
Um,
but like now when I make a shot,
I always am setting myself up for the next shot.
So everything's about angles.
It's all geometry.
It's all about you don't want to be over here.
You want to be able to hear because the natural progression is here to slide
down here for this ball.
So when I hit this ball,
you're going to hit that pink ball into that pocket.
Right.
So,
so now I'm not thinking about that.
That's easy.
What's important is getting in a good position for this ball and just speaking,
you got to hit that ball there.
Right there around there,
right?
Well I have to hit it exactly right here because that's the only way you're
gonna make it.
And then you draw a line to where the ball is.
Where the book,
well there's a lot of,
it's instinctive cause I understand where the contact point is and I'm going to
hit it with English.
Which puts are the 10 side you went with was lefthand English on it.
Spinach.
Okay.
Oh and we're dessert.
Bananas.
Yeah.
What the fuck is that?
See how the shots I can,
wow.
What are you going to do now?
I'm going to talk at that and get in position this.
Yup.
Talking about,
and that corner could that,
that's,
that feels like it's,
but the most important thing is getting out of here.
It's about getting out of here for the side pocket.
How the fuck because no,
you'd have to hit it just wipes on.
That's a hard stock season.
This is what's important getting here,
but not just here but down people.
Cause I gotta go back up to the seven.
Can't be updatable because then you've got to do all this.
Now you want to hit that,
that white ball you want to get in position where,
where do you want to stop them ball.
So I want to make sure that I have an angle on a seven ball.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna hit it low and just slide north says lie.
That's impressive.
Look at that.
So now from here,
this is for easy.
My only concern is I don't get stuck behind the 10 ball.
I get stuck behind a 10 ball,
then I don't have a shot at the eight.
So I want to play towards the danger zone,
which is like this side rail.
So I don't want to a,
I don't want to scratch,
but I don't want to get stuck behind 10
see how close I am?
Ooh Myself,
I can't see it.
But I was worried about that.
I really wanted to land like right here,
telling them,
perfect.
If I see like that kind of position,
that takes fucking years to learn how to do,
to learn how,
how hard you're supposed to be hitting the ball to make it react like that.
If you don't have a,
that kind of pinpoint precision,
that ability to manipulate.
And so pros will run like two tails at a time.
Three to the best guys can throw 10,
10,
10.
Yeah.
Especially in practice when there's no money on the line,
it's just nothing.
They're just having a good time.
Yeah.
They can run the fucking 10 racks and crazy shit.
I've run for broken run four racks in a room of nine ball,
which is way harder than enable
nine bosses.
No more money.
Well,
nine no nine ball is,
um,
is a rotation game.
April you have a bunch of different choices.
You can choose to shoot any color or any solid or any stripe,
whether any solid,
but whereas in a nine ball playing a rotation,
so every shot,
there's no options.
Salads or stripes.
You're nine ball is you're shooting the balls,
one through nine,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine you get the nine you went.
Whereas with a eight ball,
you're either saw,
odds are stripes and you'd get a lot more options.
You can pick your shots.
It's still a very tough game,
but it's not nearly,
it doesn't require much ability to move the two ball.
It's all about moving the cue ball.
Snick the last shot.
This is a crazy table too.
This isn't a regular table.
Like look,
it doesn't even fit two balls in him.
Is it?
Very,
very tight table.
So this is a protein much anymore.
It's more tight.
Dynapro table pro tables,
four and a half inches.
This table for practice.
Yeah.
Well it's like a table or for people that you know,
you don't want to any bullshit.
You don't want a ball to Bible in,
you know?
And if you didn't pick up golf,
you would have never been scared.
Scared.
I saw too many people can.
We saw too many people that picked up golf and then became fucking nuts.
They would just play all day.
And it takes too much.
You've got down time.
Like you could go play pool for an hour.
You can't play golf for an hour playing golf.
You're playing all day.
Yeah.
It's like that shit.
What's the top pool guy making Dennis a problem dog.
Shit.
Even the number one guy in the world and no one guy in the world and I made a
quarter million bucks
and there's not that many of those guys travel
silent movies.
So it's not applicable anymore.
Oh,
you're going to print something and put it out on a fucking piece of paper?
Hadn't they lost whatever,
like remaining respect that happened.
Then I lost when they publish this,
uh,
okay.
Article in their magazine or
on Angel Wings and it was this like insane justification for how drones are more
humane than other forms of warfare.
And it read like a PRP who paint like which defense contractor paid for this
bullshit cause it's just totally demented.
How's the year to go?
Yeah.
That's um,
what would you say is right?
It's like you never know what's the source of the motivation to do a story.
You know,
after you hear about Amba lions experience with CNN and that bar rain piece one
earlier,
how much of that are going on?
How much of what we're seeing on television and reading in a newspaper is
filtered through propaganda?
Probably quite a bit.
Yeah.
I was watching part of the Kimmel last night.
He had Johnny Depp,
Vaughn sneaky about how that format is just,
that's what most people are consuming.
And it's so weird because you have somebody there for five or six minutes.
They don't share anything that's important,
like you never see.
Even though I think Kim was the best late night,
I do too.
You never see like,
so Johnny was the meaning of life.
Like what should people try to do a nice view.
It's like meaningless bullshit that I've already forgotten or hadn't.
He flies back to the south of France or wherever he's from.
And that's it.
Like you to promote his new movie and you don't learn anything more about what
he believes about the world or politics.
That's a good point.
It's like the whole format was created before the much better format that we
have now.
Yeah.
And then the whole commercials,
what we're right back.
Like where are you going
right there fucking talk to him.
Like everyone knows a conversation sort of ramps up like you have a
conversation,
sit down and then you get loose and after a while and then you start really,
and it has a flow to it and that flows completely interrupted.
If you start doing a commercial every seven minutes
or whatever it is,
we don't wait that format.
Campbell does a great job because you can tell that he's really smart and uh,
I watched her,
it's was like,
he's not worried that he's going to lose his show or something.
He's nervous.
He's going to go overboard.
It,
something's going gonna just take it away.
Really.
That's the feeling I get.
Maybe that's just his personality,
but it's like you could go a lot further.
You can push things further.
You don't have to tell you though.
I mean,
it's the fucking tonight show.
I know he's not Jay Leno,
but it's still the tonight show.
People watching it now.
Half of them are probably watching it on youtube the next day.
Yeah.
But doing all these things for this hypothetical old lady in the Midwest is
going to be offended by it and I think we're seeing is like less and less a
reality.
They're dying.
Yeah.
Basically another 90 now dynamic.
I think you're right in some ways,
but the bottom line is their,
their revenues directly related to their,
the ratings
and so thinking that oh most people are going to watch it on youtube.
That doesn't translate financially.
Yeah.
Still that's the main motivation was still the financial motivation.
I mean they look,
they look at those numbers where the fund we'll comb,
they um,
they have talking detailed by the minute analysis break down and somebody 10,000
when Kendall started talking about tomatoes,
people don't care about tomatoes,
don't talk about tomatoes,
but we dropped off 1%.
You know,
when you turn,
you know,
they,
they have that,
they have like these number being countered.
Dude that's good.
Are really concerned about that stuff.
It's weird.
Did they have that sort of an attitude?
But they do believe in some of the big youtube channels and friends with the guy
who was the head of production or it those until recently.
And he was telling me that they look at everything like the number of likes and
dislikes,
and if it goes beyond
too many reds [inaudible] they'll just pull the video.
And I was like,
really?
He said they don't want to fuck up their algorithm or whatever.
They want to continuously be on the top.
So the video doesn't do as well as they expected to just get rid of it.
It's that rarely happens because they know so well with the audience wants at
this point.
What kind of videos do they make?
They do like music,
entertainment,
two minute long clips,
different discussions and stuff.
Wow.
So that's fine.
But to me a long toss is even more ridiculous when I'm talking about real stuff.
It'll be like,
I need to know about,
you know,
the Harvard or something.
[inaudible].